une arrivée tout sourire
un salut aux rares spectateurs de la
salle et le débat peut commencer dans
une ambiance particulière kamala harris
et mike pence ou font face séparés par
des parois en plexiglas virus au bij
premier sujet et pas des moindres la
question de l'épidémie ducobu 19 sur le
territoire américain
une occasion en or côté démocrate pour
pointer du doigt la gestion du président
donald trump
mais le peuple américain a été témoin de
ce qui est le plus grand échec de toute
administration présidentielle dans
l'histoire de notre pays
et voici les faits deux cent dix mille
personnes sont mortes dans notre pays au
cours des derniers mois plus de sept
millions de personnes ont contracté
cette maladie
une entreprise sur cinq a fermé je pense
que le peuple américain c'est que le
président a fait passer l'amérique et le
peuple américain en premier je crois
qu'avec mon coeur je peux être fier des
sacrifices qu'ils ont faits et les en
sauver d'innombrables vies américaines
alors que la sénatrice démocrate kamala
harris a admis ne pas vouloir se faire
vacciner si le vaccin est conseillé par
donald trump le vice-président
républicain lui s'est empressé de
l'accusé de saper la confiance des
américains continuent le fait que vous
continuez à saper la confiance du public
dans un vaccin
si le vaccin apparaît pendant
l'administration de trope est à mon avis
inadmissible et sénatrices je vous
demande simplement de cesser de faire de
la politique avec la vie des gens dans
des mines du que 8,19 sujet phare qui a
dominé les 90 minutes mais ce n'est pas
tant attendu tensions raciales écologie
ou encore système de santé les deux
colistiers ont dû mener de front ces
sujets particulièrement cruciaux et ce
dans le calme et la diplomatie sans pour
autant éviter quelques petits
accrochages notamment sur la question
des déclarations fiscales du président
sortant nous savons maintenant que
donald trump doit 400 millions de
dollars et qu'il est endetté et pour que
les choses soient claires lorsque nous
disons endettés
cela signifie que vous devez de l'argent
à quelqu'un il serait vraiment bon de
savoir à qui le président des états unis
le commandant en chef doit de l'argent
car le peuple américain le droit de
savoir ce qui influence les décisions du
président de 5
il le fait est que joe biden a été très
clair il n'augmentera pas les impôts de
ceux qui gagnent moins de 400 mille
dollars marrant il a dit qu'il
abrogerait la réduction d'impôt d'autres
hubs monsieur le vice président c'est
moi qui parle je parle un débat à la
fois musclé disciplinée qui contraste
nettement avec celui de la semaine
dernière entre donald trump et de weiden
les lieutenants des candidats semblent
avoir voulu recentrer leurs discours sur
les sujets essentiels de cette
présidentielle
les regards se tournent à présent sur le
prochain duel entre le président et son
challenger démocrate prévue le 15
octobre prochain
reste à savoir si celui ci aura lieu
compte tenu de la récente contamination
du président sortant l'ag